what happened with this this country
singer who used the n-word
he didn't really i think people kind of
galvanized did people kind of go
this is too much or what happened he's a
i mean morgan's a friend of mine he was
on a podcast
he was on a couple months ago he used it
he called his friend the n-word in the
street he came back and apologized he
said
i'm gonna try to do better and you know
the media did what they did they ripped
him up
what got me about that i mean obviously
like
it's like he called his friend [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] right to a white dude and i think
a lot of white people should be called
the n word
i got called it a bunch growing up i
still get called us sometimes by this
dude that lives in the park the black
guy by me will call me every now and
then
i like it a little i'll be honest that's
who i am makes you feel included
yeah it does something bro you know like
sometimes cool
no joke i was walking with a girl a
couple weeks ago and he the guy said it
and i know she didn't hear him and i
[ __ ] said hey say it louder bro
you know and he did and he said it
louder bro he's a black guy he can say
it right he can like in a way you feel
like he trusts you
and he knows that you're not a
prejudiced white guy right he knows i'm
not a spock
in a way he feels like he's he's saying
something it's like a term of endearment
for you like yeah it was like a code i
got to wear for a couple seconds gave me
a little bit of clout with the dame you
know
or the man whatever she was i don't know
what she's chosen to be i didn't
yeah but what got me was that and this
and and i'm
is that suddenly there were news
articles that would never even watch
morgan that was the guy's name yeah that
would never even
and they're they're using it in their
titling like the n word the n word
so they're basically using the n word to
get you to go of course
so who's really using it one guy who
uses it on the street calling his white
friend
or the white press that makes money by
getting clicks that's what burned and
it's like
man all of them go i can get the story
now i can use the n-word and now i can
get we can get more online subscriptions
there's money in clicks
yeah and as long as there's money and
clicks and there's money in telling your
readers your echo chamber exactly what
they want to hear and
what they believe anyway and already you
you will you will continue to to
polarize the press
and now you look at anything that comes
out of huffington post you're like i
know exactly how they feel so why am i
going to read this
right i mean and he came out and said
for himself you know he said you know
what he wanted to say on it so it's like
it's his thing
but some i don't know sometimes you feel
like it would be
it's just crazy how you can go and buy
the on certain platforms you can buy the
n-word and listen to it
you know you can pay two dollars for it
1.99 for a song and go listen oh yeah
you know it's like maybe don't make it
available to white people
well i think that that this guy somehow
got like he
they tried to cancel him and i think his
fans were like now we're gonna buy all
his stuff
oh he'll have the biggest tour in the
world in a couple years
his music is just great yeah i mean i
think you know uh
and he's a great kid i was at his house
a couple nights before
the video stuff and there were black
guys over there with him he had it's not
like
i'm sure i've seen racist people yeah
he's not a racist guy
he's not a racist guy so and that's
obvious to most
human people with a brain yeah but yeah
but
intention doesn't matter anymore it's
just consequence
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one